[Musique]
des poubelles jaunes sont parfois
mélangés aux poubelles vertes
pourquoi de telles pratiques nous
tentons d'en savoir plus auprès d'un
éboueur
mal à l'aise il nous tient un discours
invraisemblable
mettez la poubelle jaune et la poubelle
verte ensemble
ces pages jaunes
[Applaudissements]
c'est un geste simple et pourtant seuls
trois français sur quatre se lave les
mains après être allés au toilettes
contre par exemple 86 % chez nos voisins
allemands aux 83 % en italie
ça sent le fennec
bienvenue dans la seule édition faisant
applaudir des vaches les français des
gaulois plus réfractaires à l'hygiène
selon une étude malgré une légère
amélioration pendant l'épidémie
la france est le pays où l'on compte le
moins d'adultes qui respectent les
consignes martelé pendant la crise
sanitaire vous allez vous leur avez
beaucoup paire de seins bientôt tu sais
quoi trier les bons embêter les dans
l'ordre et puis hier on vous retrouvera
la salle d'audition fille traversait pas
on va peut-être passer à tournus visible
en faisant ça ça m'a mis du gel dans la
mairie d'abou dhabi et florent pagny
dans le nuage c'est rare de voir dans un
nuage de fumée ne
sais pas si rare que ça mais là c'est en
direct et donc pas moi le terrain
appartient à cet homme un boulanger qui
a abandonné son ancien métier pour cette
activité qui serait bien plus lucratives
le tarif pour déverser ici serait de 70
euros par camion
à quinze camions par jour cela fait près
de vingt mille euros par mois nets
d'impôts bien sûr une jolie somme pour
l'homme dont le travail se limite
désormais à dissimuler les déchets les
plus visibles
[Musique]
paix
aïe
si je bougeais
si je vous aime
[Musique]
nous sommes pris à partie par la
compagne et la fille du propriétaire
marcheurs je vais vous montrer partout
il faut filmer voulu que je fous là nous
sommes sur une décharge illégale sultan
mais donnez-moi les certificats
d'urbanisme qui vous donne
l'autorisation de décharger absolument
n'importe quoi vous venez de voir des
charges j'ai vu
c'est le procureur qui vous interrogera
pour savoir qui signa des bleus
bernard vous savez le son qu'on vient de
répondre c'est le champ de la reine
exactement la reine appels et les autres
n à venir se battre avec elle et pour
qu'on voie laquelle est la plus forte et
sûre dès qu'elle n'ait de chant de
catcheur dans le style écoute et qui
sait bien se friter avec moi parce que
c'est moi qui veut la couronne et toutes
celles qui arrivent venez je vous casser
la figure lui fait pas nous qui faisons
madame lourd ce qu on fait rentrer ses
de la terre madame
on comprend pas la nature
la tension est telle que la femme du
propriétaire jette notre caméra
je pense à je connais pas je pense à
eric zemmour z comme zorro eric je veux
juste te dire que c'est pas du tout pète
un câble sauver les juifs de france ça
c'est des conneries c'est pas ça bon
hein maman a traversé la guerre dans la
terreur tous les jours elle a eu la vie
sauve parce qu'elle a usurpé l'identité
de la première fan de mon père quand il
n'était toujours pas divorcer mais elle
m'a tellement parlé de la guerre que je
suis très imprégné par ça voilà pour le
témoignage des régimes où que ce soit
c'est pas gênant du tout c'est génial je
m'appelle corps et or est anastasia
enchanté but pareil qu'il sent prête
noms ah bon moi je suis chaud bouillant
surtout le tournage et des références
seulement sexuelle c'est vrai ouais
ouais ouais ça a été mis en place bien
sûr avec avec ça avant chaque semaine
cinq scènes de sexe vous avez un
impressionnant
c'est pour ces deuxièmes et au cas où il
ya des agressions pour que les victimes
puissent se sont référés à quelqu'un
quand la reine elizabeth 2 n'accepte
jamais un couteau en cadeau si elle ne
peut pas donner en échange un penny
voilà pourquoi
je tenais vraiment
merci à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]
ils sont prêts à défendre leur
territoire j'ai peur qu'ils attaquent et
qui me
doutais qu'ils risquent surtout de fer
s'en prendre à mon entrejambe c'est ça
tu es vont m'agripper pour me la prendre
la ds que tu veux faire le rendez vous
en terre inconnue et moi je dis oui à
bord mais à los angeles je ne connais
pas nos sont
[Rires]
glissés pas le truc et je peux pas j'ai
le vertige il faut que j'aille aux
toilettes dans des endroits normaux je
préfère
mais qu'est-ce que j'ai pas vu que vous
avez joué jouiez
[Rires]
juillet
je n'avais pas juillet vous avez joué
ensemble on vous recevez un invité pour
son film vous l'avez vu malheureusement
le film n'est pas bon vous lui dites que
c'est une merde petit b vous annulé sa
venue ou petit c'est vous ne dites rien
en même temps si vous aviez garder que
les bons films vous ne feriez que trois
émissions par an non je dis ce que deux
confrères m'ont soufflé un cd pierre
desproges tu m'a étonné
vous vous étiez une daube jeudi un vrai
univers
il ya eu des rencontres et il ya eu
aussi
aller en france quelqu'un d'important on
va je suis sûr qu'à l'oreille vous allez
tout de suite savoir où on est on est en
79 on est sur scène et un certain johnny
hallyday qui va dire ça regardez et
écoutez et en gaz
[Musique]
en
fait on va expliquer avec mes cases qui
s'est passé il ya un petit problème
technique ça arrive on en direct c'est
magnifique parce que c'est la fragilité
la puissance du direct alors c'est vrai
que je vois pas vos images où on est et
j'ai une bonne nouvelle voyez pas les
miennes non plus on voit pas de votre
complot merci beaucoup et de votre
fidélité mes amis se joignent à moi pour
vous et vous souhaiter une très belle
après-midi sur
wii on a discuté bien
du bien mais je vous dis bien celle ou à
plusieurs
[Rires]